welcome to quad Riga our topic today the
latest turn in an election that never
ceases to surprise a week after release
of an 11-year old tape in which Donald
Trump bragged about sexual assaults on
women the Republican Party is in
disarray with leading Republicans
announcing they will no longer support
the candidate Trump's poll numbers are
in freefall just a few weeks after he
appeared to be closing in on Democrat
Hillary Clinton but Trump insists he's
not quitting Sex Lies and videotape is
Trump finished that's our title question
today and we want to get some answers
from three people who are following the
US election closely it's a pleasure to
welcome Alison smail she's the Berlin
bureau chief of the New York Times and
she says I never really believed Donald
Trump would win but in this election a
lot of things have turned out
differently than expected that's why I'm
very careful when it comes to
predictions Arica Hammond is the
business editor at the Berlin daily the
tats she believes Trump's problem isn't
his sexism it's that he talked about sex
I can't imagine Trump will be elected
president and finally great to have Alan
Posner back on the show he's an Anglo
German author and regular commentator
for the berlin-based newspaper de Velde
and he says Trump was right he just said
what Bill Clinton did as this thinks in
Trump might even gain from the episode
Allison smell as i mentioned polls are
indeed taking a dramatic turn downward
for mr. Trump but the fact is that
there's always a very dynamic dynamic
phase in this final stage of the race as
unen decided voters finally begin to
make up their minds how much of a role
is this whole sextape really playing
well i think you know as i believe Andy
Rosenthal wrote in The New York Times
yesterday or the day before this showed
us a Donald Trump who we basically knew
was there basically perhaps sort of very
clearly showing us Donald Trump in that
mode now other women have come forward
to the new york
x and i'm sure they will to other media
too saying oh this wasn't just bend i
can name this incident that incident
where he behaved inappropriately so as
with the entire Trump phenomenon to
suddenly sort of say oh my gosh we
didn't know that this was him I think
everybody sort of did know so whether
this affects the race or not I'm not so
sure excuse me there's been constant
surprises in this year not just in the
United States and let's think about
brexit for instance and what I think we
can see is a world in which the
certainties we thought we had our kind
of shifting before our eyes and
everybody is adjusting to that shifting
reality so we live to be surprised there
could be another big surprise before
polling day but right now it would
appear that Donald Trump has scant
chance of winning I still wouldn't rule
it out completely my favorite example is
to think of a group of people who
arranged on facebook or some other means
of communication okay where for Trump
let's make sure we take ten people each
to the top polling station on polling
day so long as it's not a state where
you have to be registered beforehand to
vote at all you can do that it flies
under the radar of any kind of opinion
polling because it's not traditional
organization we know that Hillary
Clinton is very well organized by
conventional measures but precisely what
hasn't really worked this year is
convention let's come back in a bit to
the mechanics of the race and issues
such as polling but let me pick up on
your remark that the times has just
found two women who do in fact confirm
that it wasn't only locker room talk on
that tape Alan Posner you said that you
would agree with Donald Trump that he
simply said what Bill Clinton did but
apparently according to these claims now
published by The Times this wasn't just
talk one woman has a very clear account
of him physically groping her on a plane
so clearly their word be deeds behind
these words yeah well it's difficult as
a the only man in the room yes sort of
to say what I'm saying the first thing
is that I any man who's honest will tell
you that it's true Donald Trump says men
not have not every group of men not all
the time but mentor like that is the
first thing the second thing is okay so
Trump gropes women because he thinks
they want that right and he's he's at an
oath and a fool but Bill Clinton you
state troopers to procure his women he
slept with an internee at the White
House and Hillary's was a reaction we
should say he had a bimbo problem bimbo
meaning that's her word for you know the
women bill slept with now I this is all
so horrible I'm just saying it's not a
Republican problem is not even a
specific Trump problem it's a male
problem and it's a problem of females
women who cover for this kind of man and
I think it's you know this is it but
trampas Eddie's unshackled now because
the Republican Party is disowning him I
wonder what is gonna dig up on on on
Hillary and Bill and it's not gonna be
nice as tempting as it might be to now
open up discussion on Bill Clinton's
peccadilloes as well I'm going to leave
that aside because otherwise we won't
stay with the topic at hand which of
course is whether Trump is finished you
implied you thought he could come back
from these allegations potentially
perhaps also from two women going to the
times and telling their stories but the
fact is he needs women voters they make
up the majority of the undecided voters
do you really think that they're going
to take the same view that you just give
us I think as well firstly his his basis
was always white males of a certain
education under certain but he's got a
bride in that doesn't he's got to
broaden that and he hasn't but you know
you might find Hispanic males who
hitherto didn't like him calling
Mexicans races feeling that this sort of
match
way of talking was kind of nice you
might even find blackmail saying the
same thing you might even find you know
the kind of I mean listen to country
music you know even when sung by women
it's all about that kind of man so and
then it says stand by your man right
because after all he's just a man I
really don't know what might or might
not happen and you know I wish women
would rise up as one and say no this is
this is yeah he's had it I don't think
it's gonna happen BK I mean what do you
think but I think that the problem is
slightly different one I think that
everyone always knew that he was an oath
as you said and that he was sexist as
well I mean that was common knowledge
that is nothing new but I think the
problem is that he talked about sex in a
very buttoned way and you know the
voters he has to catch for example all
these conservative in religious voters
and they don't want to talk about sex
it's different here in Europe everyone
talks about sex actually you know he had
talked about sex plenty before remember
the debate during the primaries when he
actually more or less bragged about the
size and effectiveness of his sexual
equipment well that's true yeah but that
doesn't seem to have cost him support so
isn't there a difference here but the
difference here is actually he's talking
about know about talking about
molestation yeah exactly yeah but I
thought that well still I think that he
never ever I agree with sound that he
never ever had much chance or stood much
chance with the women and I think that
is just drove home again that he was sex
driven and I think that's very perhaps
it's not a problem for conservative
voters but i can't imagine all these tea
party guys voting for him I mean because
that's not the ideal of how you should
behave as a church-going and president
but perhaps it's not a problem I I can't
really tell but I guess it's it was
about so very blatent that you can just
not yeah I think they say in a way it's
great this happening remember when when
Bill Clinton did this stuff I mean it
was all the whole Republican Party was
up in arms like how can you and your and
this is a quest
of character rules out I mean it wasn't
just the Republican Party it was
everybody which everybody say oh my
goodness he's brought public discourse
down to a kind of a new low well here we
got that we've announced awareness now
the same the same Democrats who defended
Bill Clinton saying well that's his
private a private matter his private
parts or his private matter now they're
all accusing you know Trump and and the
great thing is that or you know the
question of who is for what and the
whole the whole moral issue the cultural
wars have been declared invalid you know
the Republican Party is supporting a
sexist oath and and and but actually the
cat loves it the Republican Party is by
no means United anymore in supporting
mr. Trump absence mill your party but
your paper published a long list of
Trump would say of course the x is a
party of it okay we'll leave that aside
your paper published a long list of
Republicans who are now deserting what
they clearly perceived to be a sinking
ship among them just most recently John
McCain Arnold Schwarzenegger Condoleezza
Rice all saying they can't vote for mr.
Trump you know isn't there a certain
element of hypocrisy here it has been
perfectly show on politics that exists
without hypocrisy but I would like to go
back a little bit to your point that
what happens afterwards is really kind
of the important thing here I think and
whether it's the culture wars whatever
these are all substitutes for what is
essentially a struggle for power which
traditionally in the United States has
been framed as a struggle between
Democrats and Republicans broadly
speaking people of the sword of center
right and broadly speaking center more
left but I'm not so sure that left and
right are particularly helpful because
those European terms don't really apply
when you get to us politics so I think
it's much more interesting to see what
will remain of this fight the day after
there is a
decision and what will the reality after
the election do to resolve the basic
issues that it has thrown up and which
is not going to be solved by the choice
of either Clinton or Trump per se can we
just come back to that a little bit
later I do absolutely want to focus on
that point toward the end but I'd like
to take a brief look first at the storm
that has been unleashed by release of
the tape and in particular at the
Twitter storm that mr. Trump himself has
now Unchained Trump launched a
blistering attack on House Speaker Paul
Ryan the country's highest ranking
Republican despite winning the second
debate in a landslide it is hard to do
well when Paul Ryan and others gives
zero support Trump called Ryan a very
weak and ineffective leader and then
this it's so nice that the shackles have
been taken off me and i can now fight
for America the way I want to
so Ellen Posner as I said your opening
statement implies that you do think
Trump can come back from this but does
he not need the republican party
organization where his own campaign
organization is so weak on the ground
particularly in the swing states doesn't
he need their backing and he is now
absolutely flouting them well the first
thing you have to say is it again he's
he's right in that is he's cast off the
shackles I mean McCain says now he can't
vote for Trump and he could vote for
someone who called Mexicans are rapists
who could who said in a TV show that a
woman had blood coming out of her that
was all right then you know I mean come
on the whole I think you know all these
people who are now against Trump from
Republican Party I'm saying guys and
gals are some of them yeah you're too
late right so if he's casting them off
if they're I think it will in fact I'm
galvanize his support which was never
over the traditional Republican
apparatus I think he really has a chance
to say you know these are his whole
pitch has been I'm the new guy I'm not
part of the establishment I say what I
think I do what I say and you know I
think it'll work it'll work with with
the sort of aggressive resentment lady
mayor Votto's has finally there's a
there's a guy who's a real metro and
doesn't kowtow to these Washington
politico's I'm not even sure it's
resentment Laden people only honestly I
think that there is you know Americans
always questing for something new and
there's a willingness to sort of say
well you know maybe this I get this guy
is going to shake things up I found it
interesting that ken Bohn the unexpected
hit of the second debate the man who
wore his red sweater on television and
posed a question about energy in one of
the many interviews he then did
afterwards after became an internet
sensation for at least five minutes and
he sort of said well
economically you ought to be going with
Trump because he works in the coal
sector and what Trump is sort of saying
more echoes closely the the nature of
his day-to-day problems but that it
would be impossible for him personally
to do that because things like marriage
equality and other rights that have been
won by minorities are too hard fought a
victory to be given up I just found that
interesting very interesting because
this was not somebody who was you know
frothing at the mouth with anger on
either on either score he was just
taking a very fairly sanguine look and
he did not out of hand reject Trump's
arguments while at the same time
praising things that are much more
likely to put him in the Hillary camp
but I think well you're right when you
say that the conservative establishment
could have somehow be angry with a trump
before because of what he had said but I
think the interesting thing is that and
I think that's what it is all about that
the survey is clearly showed that [ __ ]
lost support let's say for the last four
weeks and then you know this
conservative establishment was just
looking for a good reason to somehow get
away from [ __ ] before it is too late
for them it's gone or they not gone for
them it's clear that they will lose the
race for presidency and now the only
question is how to keep the majority in
the house and what to do afterwards they
do not want to be part of the sinking
ship so they all went overboard as as
soon as possible and this video was just
an excuse to get rid of Trump but they
would have found another excuse if this
video hadn't been excavated by The
Washington Post but particularly strange
is the fact that some of the rats that
have plunged from the ship are now
apparently sort of halfway trying to
crawl back on at least four members of
the House and Senate now apparently said
they were really rejecting the top of
the ticket they were just kind of you
know a little disturbed about
Ellen Posner the Republican Party is in
tremendous disarray do you really
believe that polls are so inaccurate
that at the end of the day they can come
back from this to win the election both
for the presidency and both chambers of
of the Congress well yes I do just short
answer but I think the problem is really
um the party is in disarray because it
has nothing to do everything the party
stands for the party of Abraham Lincoln
for God's sake has nothing to do with
what Trump stands for the problem with
Trump I mean yeah I hate what he said
about women the real problem is what
he's saying about mr. Putin for instance
that he thinks he's a nice guy that he
could get on with him for instance or
that he somehow thinks in the same
breath he says that you know he could
deal with Isis in a stroke of the pen
and then wanted to build this war on
immigration these are the real problems
it has no coherent policy and the
policies he has have nothing to do with
the sort of small government basically
liberal in the economic sense policies
that shall we say Mitt Romney or on a
Reagan stood for and this is the really
terrible thing there's a you know if he
actually got into the White House what
would he do with that party I yeah I
mean he wouldn't what would he do with
that position of power who would he
appoint to govern within the minutes
it's all very unclear we might form a
new party which to the subsea I mean
very possibly but we've known that the
Republican Party has been in some
disarray for some years the appearance
of the Tea Party has basically forced an
ideological struggle upon the
Republicans and that has been in full
swing for at least the past two major
national elections if not longer the
assessment of many people of course was
that the approach that was taken by
Donald Trump at this latest debate and
the approach he's essentially using now
that he's unshackled is to throw red
meat at his core voters many of whom are
disgusted
with the party elite in the Republican
regs let's take a look at one of those
core Trump voters with whom my
colleagues in the u.s. spoke Rancher Jim
Chilton shows us around his property in
southern Arizona more than 200 square
kilometers part of it runs along the
border with Mexico chilton says the US
government is not doing enough to
protect him and other local ranchers
from Mexican smugglers these pictures
were taken last year by hidden cameras
on Jim's property hilarious to think
that the United States boundary on my
ranch is nothing but a 4-strand
barbed-wire fence jim says the border
authorities should replace that with a
real fence plus checkpoints and more
frequent patrols right now the nearest
border station is about three hours
north of here why not have a wall and
roads and why not allow people to come
in this country legally
so Allan Poe's no you didn't really
believe Trump's boasting when it came to
his prowess with women do you believe
his claims about building the wall he
says it's the first thing he's gonna do
when he gets into the White House do you
think he'll follow through if he's
elected yeah why not I mean I think he
can do it um you might not get Mexico to
pay for it as he says he will but he can
he can do what that rancher said he can
put up her I mean there already is along
the Rio Grande a whole lot of you know
protective devices and so on e do all he
needs to do is to increase that of
course you can do it um it fences are
going up in Europe all over round brown
round nations all over the place it's a
horrible thing and is he's part of a
trend we have just a few minutes left
and I really would like to come back to
the question that Allison's meal posed a
bit earlier on about what happens on the
day after two of you believe that the
day after will be in the hands of
Hillary Clinton Alan Posner believes it
could wind up being in the hands of
Donald Trump regardless who you think is
going to win a lot of ghosts have been
let out of the bottle in the course of
this election we've had some of the most
vulgar poisonous discourse that we have
ever seen in a u.s. election what
happens after this election how does the
US come back from that we can happen
well I think it's the most important
question is whether the Republicans will
have a majority in the house and in the
Senate if they lose just the presidency
for them it's no problem because then
they would just continue what they did
when Obama was president they would just
abstract every kind of policy and then
claim that there was no possible no
political aim at Washington as was
somehow worth fighting for but in other
words that is exactly the recipe for a
continuation examining of what we had
missed the paralysis of the polarization
exactly it fed the anger that website
Lee and that's something that
Republicans apparently don't understand
I don't have the feeling that Paul Ryan
understands why the Republicans are
losing power they still think I guess
that it is a very good idea to just
constant
obstructing policy or politics and what
is the basic issue that has to be
addressed is that the majority of the
Americans lose out for the for the last
40 years the salaries in real terms have
not risen for the majority but
everything became more expensive
summarized in middle class income in the
past year but yeah but in yeah but you
can just look at the statistics for the
last 40 years nothing happened for those
for the majority and at the same time
everything became more expensive and
especially the universities so and
that's why is there was such a big
student unrest and because that's why
they all support Bernie Sanders and you
really have to address these issues if
you want the American if you want to be
in the United States would be a country
that can be ruled Allison smell another
aspect we've seen some very strong
denigrating of us institutions on the
part of Donald Trump your paper found
the most disturbing aspect of the most
recent debate not the discussion about
the sex tape but Donald Trump's call for
a special prosecutor who would throw
Hillary Clinton in jail that's not us
constitutional democracy does that do
lasting damage to us institutions well I
think it certainly poses a test for
those institutions and that's precisely
what we've seen across the board this
year and I do think we just need to ask
ourselves the very basic question what
is democracy and do we as the german
historian fritz Stan said in one of his
last interviews before he died sadly
earlier this year you know democracy
must be defended as what he said and I
think that that's the basic question
that we all have to ask ourselves and
when kind of forget all the storm and
drying about every peccadillo of mr.
Trump or every sort of question about
Hillary Clinton's behavior as Secretary
of State the wisdom of using this
private email server and move beyond
those specific issues none of which are
so trivial to the very basic question
what are we going to do with our future
we all know that the world is changing
rapidly some of the reason why we've
seen people like mr. Trump rise is
because people are looking for
they perceived to be certainty in a very
quickly shifting world and so it is up
to us I think to sort of orient
ourselves talk towards our basic values
and their the question is will the
Republican Party finally sort of have
the debate in touch settle its own
internal debate and will it continue to
have influence through the Senate and
the house or is the Democratic where a
prospect about Democratic majority and
Alan very briefly if you would please
what happens to Donald Trump himself you
say he's not finished does he just go
back to business as usual no he forms a
fascist party ms missile genic party to
fight Hillary Clinton if he's in the
presidency he forms also yours and forms
a fascist party to ensure the
continuance of his rule if he loses
America is even more divided than it is
now and that's was gonna do very
dystopian last words thank you very much
to all of you for being with us today
and thanks to all of you out there for
tuning in see you soon
you